we were talking about pvp and
you know one thing that i think is
really interesting
about pvp in overwatch too
is some of the philosophical changes
we're making to the approach pvp feels
different new we're upgrading our combat
feel
the roles are playing differently when
it comes to all new maps
it's a pretty big departure uh from
where we are
on live right now so i i can't wait to
see where we end up with it by the time
we launch this thing
we're also experimenting with the idea
we call roll passives which are passive
abilities that a hero can have
based on what role they are for example
currently in our internal builds
the tank heroes all have knockback
reduction against them
and they also generate less ultimate
charge for enemies they're shooting at
them
damage dealing heroes have a movement
speed bonus which is great for
flanking around the map and healing
heroes support heroes have
automatic healing that kicks in after
they haven't taken damage for a while
very similar to mercy's passive but a
little bit of a lower rate
one of the more shocking changes that
we've been exploring
in overwatch 2 pvp is it changed the
tank roll entirely
that's applied to all of the tanks we
want to try to make them
more toe-to-toe brawlers and less
characters that just stand back and
protect other people
so for example for reinhardt we've given
him two charges of fire strike so we can
throw
fire strikes a lot more aggressively and
more often also his charge
he's able to cancel it now and you can
steer it more aggressively so you can
you know not quite turn a corner but you
can definitely more accurately pin
targets and
because you can cancel it it allows you
to use it much more aggressively and
you know really go after those key
targets without feeling like you're
going to sacrifice
you know all of your positioning
everything to get there he's almost more
terrifying now with us to be able to
unleash his full arsenal more often than
kind of just being the guy with a shield
the changes to reinhardt that we're
trying
and they might not shift that's just the
reality but the changes
that we're trying right now are to try
to embrace
more of that instinct that players have
when they want to play
a big burly character that looks
aggressive
and feels like it should be aggressive
shortly after blizzcon we we spun up
this group our combat feel group
to really just work on what happens
when a player holds the trigger we're
putting a ton of effort into
looking at all of our characters um and
trying to
give them even a more visceral weapon
feel
from sound to vfx to animation
to the design of these units all new
sounds for
for a lot of our weapons in the game and
a whole new sound
system that's driving it and we didn't
just level up a unit
we leveled up the rest of the game
when we first started working on
overwatch email we spent quite a bit of
time working on
gunfire sounds and just just general
combat feel to make it feel really
awesome
we're revisiting pretty much everything
nothing's off the table so we're looking
at
even kind of small things such as quick
melee attacks that every hero has so
they have kind of new audio paths and a
new kind of
feel and the visual effect we hit things
one of the bigger efforts we're
undertaking for overwatch 2
is what we're calling our weapon 2.0
sound pass
what this is a big overhaul to the
weapon systems in the game
that means the way the gun feels in your
hands you could feel the ammo running
out as you're getting lower on the clip
we've really tried to
amplify those sounds to better
encapsulate the gameplay
and the gun play that comes with
overwatch too
another key for the weapons was getting
them to feel like they're in the
environment this meant working with
convolution reverb it's a new system
that we've implemented into overwatch
it's a way that we can capture the
acoustics of an environment
and transport it onto the sounds that
we're using so we went and captured
tales of guns in different environments
through our weapon shoots
wow
and then we've cut them and applied it
so that we can support a lot more
environments
now we're sporting outdoor urban
outdoor warehouse tales
tight tunnels small rooms and it gives a
lot more presence to the weapons in the
way that they react in the world the
shooter genre has evolved
a lot since overwatch one came out on
top of that i think we really want to
push the visceral nature of how we do
combat
so we focused a lot not just on the
wonderful sound effects but
also with how the the gun moves as you
shoot you know
so you can really feel every single shot
leaving the chamber and there's a lot of
subtle little tweaks we have to do
on the gameplay engineering side to make
that feel really visceral
everything from making sure that the
camera shakes are crisp
making sure that if you get shot you
know exactly these tight indicators show
up on the outside of your reticle
all these things play into making the
game feel not just
tight and responsive but also modern and
up to date
take 76 for example what we wanted to do
in overwatch 2 with his weapon
was to make it really feel incredibly
powerful and that happens with a bunch
of different elements that mix together
but it really feels like the gun is
almost just outside of your control
a lot of that comes down to this camera
shake technology where every set every
time you fire the weapon
you want to feel like it's running
through your entire body and the camera
shake gives that extra bite to every
single shot out of the chamber
it makes him feel really great you guys
got a sneak peek of
sojourn from last blizzcon she's been
under development for quite a while
and she's actually quickly at this point
become a lot of people's favorites
in-house when we look back at overwatch
when it was originally
created um there was a lot of heroes
that were made from a gameplay
standpoint kind of surrounding
a weapon type for example pharah was
based on a rocket launcher hero
widowmaker is clearly like kind of the
sniper we thought there was a weapon
that was kind of
missing that would be a lot of fun to
play with and that's a railgun it's so
much fun in the play test to have this
really powerful shot that can
you know rip through enemies if you
really are accurate with it and she's
she's all about the name skill so if you
got that aim skill you'll love her